saludos hemos resuelto muchos problemas
con vectores sobre todo el movimiento de
proyectiles siempre nos dan un vector
como este como el que he dibujado aquí
como diciendo que algo tiene una
velocidad de 10 metros por segundo con
un ángulo por encima de la horizontal de
30 grados y después lo que hacíamos es
descomponer este vector en sus elementos
vertical y horizontal y aquí hubiera
usado la notación debe x o el componente
de la velocidad en el eje x que sería
este elemento horizontal de aquí del
vector
este de aquí para que se note mejor y
para el componente vertical que sería
este este de acá usaría esta anotación
el componente y de la velocidad es desde
y este es de x
y que espero que para este momento
ustedes ya están muy familiarizados
acerca de cómo encontrar estos valores o
estos vectores aquí b x es 10 por el
coseno de 30 grados esto es igual a 10
por el costo de 30 grados que eso es de
3 entre 2 pero no vamos a abundar en
esto en este momento y ver si es igual a
10 por el seno del ángulo de 30 grados
como les comenté yo espero que ustedes
ya estén familiarizados con esto si no
lo están revisando nuestros vídeos de
soft captó a para que vean que el seno
de 30 grados es el cateto opuesto entre
la hipotenusa y el coseno de 30 grados
es el cateto adyacente entre la
hipotenusa y de ahí vienen esos valores
y eso ya lo hemos venido haciendo
durante varios vídeos y lo que quiero
que veamos ahora ya que esto sólo nos es
útil para problemas muy sencillos de
movimiento de proyectiles es comenzar a
trabajar con vectores un poquito más
complejos quizás con vectores
multidimensionales
de tres dimensiones o tal vez cuando
veamos álgebra dimensional trabajemos
con vectores de n dimensiones y para
todo esto necesitaremos una forma
analítica para representar vectores ya
que no siempre vamos a poder hacer
dibujos de estos vectores lo que hacemos
es usar algo llamado notación de
vectores unitarios esto quiere decir que
se tienen definidos ciertos vectores
permítanme dibujar un par de ejes y
quizá esto les parezca un poquito
confuso pero tengan en cuenta que esto
es lo mismo que hemos venido haciendo
durante todos estos problemas terminamos
de dibujar los ejes más o menos así
aquí está
el 1 este es 2
este es el eje x este es mi origen y lo
mismo tenemos aquí un 12 y este es el
eje y vamos a definir nuestros vectores
unitarios en dos dimensiones voy a
definir un vector que le voy a llamar i
y que está aquí y está justo encima del
eje de las x no tiene componente ni y
tiene magnitud de 1
este es el vector que estoy definiendo y
lo llamo
y lo decidimos porque tiene este como
sombrerito aquí arriba como si fuera una
punta de flecha y hay diferentes
notaciones a veces en los libros ustedes
se pueden encontrar está ahí sin este
sombrerito a lo mejor en negritas y
otras notaciones varias pero bueno este
es nuestro vector y unitario está hacia
la derecha sobre el eje de las equis y
su magnitud es de 1 voy a definir otro
vector ya éste le voy a llamar
este vector va de aquí a acá lo pongo un
poquito más grueso para que se note
mejor eso está por completo en el eje y
va hacia arriba sobre este eje su
magnitud es de 1 y se llama vector
unitario jota también con este
sombrerito aquí arriba para que estoy
haciendo esto cuando estamos trabajando
con dos dimensiones y más adelante lo
veremos en tres dimensiones
podemos definir cualquier vector en dos
dimensiones en términos de estos
vectores unitarios y j con respecto a
algún múltiplo de estos vectores si
tuviéramos un vector en tres dimensiones
tendríamos otro vector unitario que
llamaríamos acá pero ahorita no se
preocupen lo veremos más adelante por
ahorita recuerden que podemos definir
cualquier vector en dos dimensiones como
la suma de múltiplos de estos vectores
unitarios y j por ejemplo este vector b
es la suma de este vector b x que es
horizontal más el vector que es el
vertical recuerden que cuando sumamos
vectores ponemos el origen de un vector
justo donde termina el otro vector y al
unir este origen con esta punta tenemos
la suma de estos dos vectores y
recordando todo lo que ya hemos visto en
estos vídeos sabemos que nuestro vector
velocidad es igual a su componente en x
más su componente en g y podemos definir
bebé x como un múltiplo de i de este
vector unitario de acá ya que este
vector de x va en la misma dirección en
la que va nuestro vector y unitario y
pero este vector x no tiene una magnitud
de 1 tiene una magnitud de 10 coseno de
30 grados
voy a dibujar el vector unitario y aquí
en simi te espero que se note
el componente horizontal de mi vector
velocidad
estévez x este es mi vector unitario
así que este vector b x va exactamente a
la misma dirección que éste y solo que
tiene una magnitud más grande y de hecho
va a ser un múltiplo de y ya que este
vector unitario mide 1 y este tiene una
magnitud de 10 por coseno de 30 grados
que me parece es igual a 5 por raíz
cuadrada de 3 así que podemos escribir
bebé x de x
igual a 10 coseno de 30 grados x mi
vector unitario y tiene este sentido
bueno ya habíamos comentado varias veces
este vector y va en la misma dirección
que el vector x solo que la magnitud de
x va a ser un múltiplo de la magnitud
del bebé x va a ser mucho más largo que
de hecho va a ser 10 coseno de 30 grados
más grande que y de hecho esto es igual
a 5 por raíz cuadrada de 3
por y de la misma manera podemos
escribir estévez
como un múltiplo del vector unitario j
director unitario j lo dibujó aquí
espero que se note voy a remarcar lo
tomas de veces está aquí este es mi
vector unitario j así que podemos
escribir que ve de iu
es igual a 10 por el seno de 30 grados
multiplicado por el vector unitario jota
nuevamente ese vector unitario va en la
misma dirección que belle solo que belle
es más grande que el vector j de hecho
puedo simplificar esto seno de 30 grados
es igual a un medio por lo que vélez es
igual a 10 entre 25 j bay es un múltiplo
de jota y de hecho es 5 veces el vector
unitario jota y ahora sí cómo podemos
expresar nuestro sector de ya vimos que
el vector b es la suma de estos dos
sectores y aquí tengo b x en términos de
y es igual a 5 raíz cuadrada de 3
+ 5 por mi vector unitario j y lo que
tenemos aquí ya que hemos definido estos
vectores unitarios que aquí los tenemos
en dos dimensiones pero eventualmente
podemos aplicar exactamente lo mismo en
más dimensiones es que podemos expresar
de manera analítica cualquier sector
multidimensional o en este caso de dos
dimensiones en lugar de tener que estar
dibujando como le hemos hecho hasta el
momento nuestro vector original y
dibujar cada uno de sus elementos
vertical y horizontal podemos quedarnos
en el modo analítico y no en el modo
gráfico y esto nos es bastante útil ya
que con este formato puedo sumar y
restar vectores de manera analítica en
lugar de tener que estar dibujando cada
uno de los vectores e irnos agregando de
manera que tenga yo mi suma o mi resta
veamos un ejemplo voy a hacer un poco de
espacio supongamos que aquí tengo un
vector a que es igual a 2
+ 3 j y tengo otro vector que le voy a
llamar b y como es vector de dibujo aquí
su flechita
que es igual a
y
+ 2 j si yo quisiera encontrar cuál es
la suma del vector más el vector b antes
de tener esta anotación lo que yo
hubiera tenido que hacer es dibujar
primero el vector a y después dibujar al
vector b poniendo su origen en donde
terminó el vector y luego unir el origen
del primero con la punta del último y
así tener el vector suma de estos dos
nos hubiera llevado bastante tiempo
hacerlo pero ahora que tenemos ya
nuestro componente x y directamente
expresado acá podemos sumar de forma
separada el componente x y el componente
y así que si quiero sumar a más b va a
ser igual a los elementos del componente
en x
2 10
y
más los elementos de el componente
vertical y 32 j y esto es igual a 12
le puedo poner este puntito para que se
note bien que es la y no solamente la
gorrita más 325 jota y aquí tenemos ya
nuestro vector suma de estos dos y lo
que ustedes pueden hacer y que a lo
mejor hago en otro vídeo es de hecho
dibujar estos dos vectores dibujar el
vector suma y ver si es igual al
resultado que me da haciendo esta
operación de manera analítica y conforme
vayamos avanzando en futuros vídeos
sobre este tema
veremos cómo esto va a ser tremendamente
útil sobre todo en problemas de física y
también cuando comencemos a ver física
con cálculo nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo